we turn now to a major anniversary for
the united states air force the military
branch is celebrating its 75th year this
month throughout its history the air
force has distinguished itself with
innovation and cutting edge technology
now it faces challenges like low
recruitment numbers and escalating
tensions overseas from europe to asia
frank kendall was sworn in as air force
secretary in 2021 he is a west point
graduate and served as an army officer
for 11 years secretary hannigal kendall
good morning good to see you thank you
good to be with you so uh i had the
opportunity before uh the pandemic to
spend some time with the eighth fighter
wing in gunsan south korea and i was up
in a backseat of an f-16 and this wasn't
a joy ride we were actually on a
training mission to the dmz uh where uh
captain cassette uh simulated a bomb
drop on an enemy target and
surface-to-air missile invasion and i
just thought to myself i remember
thinking to myself this is the cutting
edge of the air force and we are just we
could see the enemy
from the cockpit in this world that is
changing right now what does the future
of air combat look like
20 years from now we're working hard
right now on the next generation of air
dominance
the two premier aircraft we have in the
inventory today is fighters are the f-35
and the f-22
the f-35 is the newer of the two the
f-22 has been around for a long time
we're moving to a replacement program
for that and we're well down the road on
that
we're also introducing the idea of
uncrewed combat aircraft which would be
under the control of a manned aircraft
but provide additional tactical
capability and be managed by that manned
aircraft
uh working together essentially as a
family of systems mr secretary i'd love
to talk about recruitment for a second
we mentioned challenges it's across all
four branches of the military and one of
the issues is not only finding people
who want to serve but finding people who
qualify to serve some of the pentagon's
own data suggest that more than 70
percent of 17 to 24 year olds young
people in this country do not reach do
not meet the educational psychological
uh or or physical requirements that's a
national security issue is it not it is
the air force is meeting its recruiting
goals for active force we're a little
bit short this year on the garden
reserve
and we're doing a number of things to
address that
basically the opportunity to serve in
the military particularly for me the air
force or the space force is a tremendous
opportunity and we just need to
communicate that to people you get a
chance to do interesting exciting and
important work you get to serve your
country uh you get to prepare yourself
for a career either in the service or
outside of it uh in a very positive way
so we're we're actively upping our
recruiting game i was going to ask you
what's your pitch and you've just sort
of laid out the pitch very nice i wasn't
going to miss the opportunity i i find
it very very compelling i almost went to
a service academy out of uh high school
uh and but i it does concern me looking
at the number of young people who don't
even if they want to serve they can't i
mean how do you change that
we're making some modifications for
where people are going to have jobs that
aren't as physically demanding as some
military jobs space force for example is
making some changes there uh some jobs
in the air force some jobs require a lot
of physical capability
almost all of our jobs require
reasonable mental capability uh
intellectual capability
so we're doing some things to adjust on
our side as well you also mentioned
space force can you just what exactly is
it who gets to join who gets to play and
how does that work what are your goals
there because we all hear the term space
force it means many things to different
people the space force is now coming up
on three years old uh it was created
primarily out of air force units but
also units from the navy
and the army as well uh it's a
relatively small service it's similar in
some ways to the marine corps being part
of the department of the navy and that
the space force is part of the
department of the air force how many
people in space force would you say
active duty it's about 8 500
so it's it's relatively small but it's
very important the mission is critical
to our national security
uh the programs that they do and the
services that they provide as well as
the ability to contest for control of
space which is becoming increasingly
necessary is a really important mission
mr secretary i've got a genuine question
about ufos not as like little green men
and aliens but the idea that there could
be some sort of technique
yeah you got the secretary to laugh and
smile for a moment there so i think
that's that's a good question no i mean
the ufc what's wrong with little greek
man i mean there's military video uh of
aviators who have seen things that
cannot be explained right and there's an
active investigation i think the worry
is not that it's little green men but
that it's a a another country with
technology that we've not seen before so
what where from where you sit are ufos a
real issue
um to be quite honest not for me um i
have real threats that i worry about
every day and there's severe threats
um i'm aware of i don't have direct
responsibility for investigating uh
these phenomena uh i've looked at the
reports i've seen what's been there
there are things that we haven't been
able to explain but i think that the
important thing for us to do is do some
ex some real technical investigation of
what they are and try to resolve these
i'm curious about what you really do
worry about you said it's not a worry
for you what do you really worry about
as you sit here today with us china
china china
i came back into government
after being out for 15 years in 2010
and i observed right away that china was
from the intelligence reports that china
was trying to fuel the set of
capabilities designed to defeat the
united states in the vicinity of china
to deny its ability to project power
close to the vicinity of china and in
the last dozen years they've continued
down that path they've been fairly
open-minded and innovative
technically reasonably sophisticated
they've identified what they think are
the the high value targets for them to
attack
includes things like aircraft carriers
our forward air bases and our satellites
in space
uh and so we have a formidable problem
there that we have to address and so
when people say that why are you
spending money on the next generation of
fighters f-22s and f-35s when we have
aircraft already capable of destroying
95 of the world's air forces you say
because we're not focused on those
threats this is the threat the pacing
challenge as we call it is china and
it's because of their military
modernization program they have the the
resources they have the strategic intent
and they have the capability and the
scale to basically contest the united
states as dominance
we've been very comfortable with our
position of dominance since the first
gulf war too comfortable frankly i'm i'm
a i'm i was a cold warrior i spent the
first 20 years of my career worrying
about the soviet union so i know
viscerally what it is like to have a
pure competitor we have one and if i
were to characterize china today i'd say
it is more severe of a competitor than
the soviet union was in 1983 you're
saying
your 75th anniversary you're still new
to the job you like it i love the job
i've got a great leadership team i've
got a very important mission that
everybody's dedicated to and performing
very well at it's a very professional
organization i'm delighted to have the
opportunity to secretary kendall
congratulations on 75 years uh the air
force not you personally but the force
itself uh and it is a great option for
young people you can get one you want to
go absolutely thank you thank you